[Music]
so you just saw a bunch of wild footage
you might notice that not all of it is
salad and that's because today we are
exploring great salads and the foods
that you eat with them to make them so
great today I'm worth it we're gonna be
trying three salads at three draftee
different price points to find out which
one is the most birthday and it's bread
this is going to be a giant episode I
mean first off what is a salad fruit
salad is it a salad macaroni salad yes
sadly this is one that I cannot believe
we're doing in a lot of ways it feels
like the spiritual successor to our
toast video they said we couldn't do it
you know salad who said we couldn't do
it
where's my salad dance you have a salad
dance yeah having danced for us in a
while Steve you gotta start with
plucking the greens plucking the greens
mixing the ball mixing the ball
our first salad is a papaya salad
brought to us by chef plow and chef fern
jus of LA's most celebrated Thai chefs
they opened a number of tyrants we're
going to love to eat Thai Bistro here it
is the thesis of this video all of the
best foods get better when you add a
salad much like Adam on this show right
because you could have a good meal but
you can't have a great meal without Adam
I mean it's Alex what kind of restaurant
is loved to eat we want people to come
and eat and feel like this eating at
friend's house is a lot is the more we
must sell up in Thailand it's spicy and
sour and sweet I love that today I want
to make a medium spicy okay other people
who work here just her do you say medium
spicy and they were like oh that's very
spicy
yeah this way we have the side like tell
people that is really hot yeah I want to
try your medium spicy okay for the
papaya fella he's have green papaya Thai
eggplant is that it's not the same here
the long one the wrong one yeah and
crispy cut this more pieces and put in
the mortar together with the sauce harm
sugar lime juice tamarind sauce fish
sauce and parting why is it important to
pound it instead of chopping and mixing
the ingredients you want a sauce inside
the wettable so you're like crushing the
vegetables and then the flavors go in
you're putting forever intuitive
vegetable yeah like real spicy and
simple but the tent is authentic is it
usually eaten as an appetizer or with
the meal in estimator we put everything
in common good I love that if the food
is done bring it out right like no need
to wait and so the dish that we're gonna
pair this with is The Crying tiger why
is it called The Crying tiger because
Eve bond heart still headless ow
Oh sounds like a tiger that's crying
right my moms will me like man I don't
know about this story my mom my mom told
me like that and then I think we're also
gonna have Jade noodle it's made from
Phoenix and we topping with roasted duck
barbecue pork crispy pork awesome and
say the heater oh ho baby cute
shall I serve you some selfies oh my
goodness I'm eating this like pasta
that's a good call you can twirl it up
like pasta
Cheers that is insanely good it's
lingering yes now tickling the back of
my throat the spice yeah a little bit of
a you know a lover's tickle
so on the spectrum of tickles this is
like a feather not just like the full
coochie-coochie-coochie-coo I love the
way this days you can't hold on to any
one flavor you're like yeah tastes a
little shrimp then they peanut oh here's
why no it's a little spicy how do you
mean not gonna be the best part of the
sound yet the texture the texture yeah
let's try some crying tiger
yes that is exactly what I want
juicy marinated steak dipping in this
very fishy sauce we'll get in surf and
turf here Jade noodle made neuters this
is a bitters whoa sorry yeah just seeing
the color right now it's green what I'm
going crazy right now
but you sound a little crazy this is
amazing with this one noodle do I eat
the whole thing in one go I mean
obviously elbow struggle I feel like I'm
gonna regret saying this but I could
have had this salad a little bit spicier
let's know some more Chili's on here so
what is this homemade despises
scary-looking be careful oh okay haha
you are you're finishing this plate
young man alright now we do the Figge
right yes we usually grab and make it
like a ball and dip well you want
spicier right touch no I'm guys there
you go
whoo-hoo spicy her this is the first
time I've been at a table where there
was beefy steak crispy pork noodles and
the thing that's gone is the salad the
salad that was a very unique salad great
example of what a salad can be it
doesn't have to have leaves just like
this a lot that we made this morning
we're eating ambrosia salad truly one of
the most bizarre salads in existence we
couldn't find a place selling it so we
had to make our own we actually got the
recipe from a former colleague of ours
Scott Loy who's now a producer at the
New York Times he grew up eating this
he's a staunch supporter of the
Ambrosius salad driving to our next
salad location perfect opportunity to
try your ambrosia salad it smells
delicious
it doesn't sound delicious
oh this isn't like a dessert course I
guess pull over and eat this actually
liked it a lot you know it's not that
crazy it is a dessert for sure it's just
like all the ingredients of a cake - the
actual case sound fact salad fact
somebody else's halifax thank you
the literal translation of ambrosial in
Greek is immortality it was originally
the name used for food that could only
be consumed by gods and goddesses in
Greek and Roman mythology pretty big
praise for this salad sense though I
think it's more that you have to have
this strength of a god to eat this as a
salad well thanks for chatting Scots
we're headed now to p3 emotes a
throwback to our very first episode
together this time we're going to meet
with the chef/owner of Petri of Malta
Nancy Silverton I am so excited about
this Nancy Silverton is a Los Angeles
restaurant legend we're gonna be trying
her salad as she put her name on it has
to be so good we got to get a little
pizza - right it's a little taste
I'm cool with that
[Music]
what makes a really good salad it's not
easy to make a salad people just think
of it as tossing but you've agreed
against together in composing the salads
I think each one has to serve a purpose
chopped really what you're eating is a
chopped up antipasti tray you're getting
salami pepperoncini onions that salad
works because you can get a bite of each
ingredient in one mouthful iceberg
lettuce and ridiculous I really love
always season those lettuces with kosher
salt fresh lemon juice toss that sliced
provolone or bon Sabine's sungold cherry
tomatoes the yellow super-sweet ones
that's toss with oregano vinaigrette and
piled high for the drama right that cell
goes by and everybody can say oh I'll
have one of those would you do us the
honor of building out a perfect meal
with some zipless salad so I think with
an old-school chopped
you're gonna go old school huh now put
Pizza also know this pizza is named
after my son his name is Benjamin and so
we call it Pizza Alabama sounds better
than pizza all our bad but my son would
always order the pineapple pizza and I'm
like that is awful how could you do it
you know you knew that pineapple came
from the can and it was sweet and it had
I think Canadian bacon you know but it
was really the worst choice so I was
determined to make one that I would even
like the pizza is definitely the focus
of this restaurant and how can he a
piece about salad yeah we came back the
pizzeria Monza two years ago to the day
probably not yeah it's not completely
made that up now we've been upgraded to
the wine cellar room Cheers mmm
a dangerous wine it's very smooth and I
have to deflate salad Mountain a little
bit it really doesn't look like any
salad I've seen before just the size of
the ingredients the density of it it
really looks like stuff that fell out of
an Italian sub like the color palette
here light pastel dish colors I mean
look at what I'm wearing
Cheers
now it's such a good salad oh it's not
tomato that thing burst like a piece of
boba the acidity of this salad is making
me want to eat bread and savory stuff
next I have like five analogies I could
use but they're all gross count them off
it's like wetting your toothbrush before
putting toothpaste on there it's a
must-do if you don't do it you're
monster number two putting water on a
waterslide before you go down you're
asking for your skin to be peeled off if
you don't do that three bedroom
activities I'm getting concerned about
the lubrication theme of all these
comments for I'm done ahead of the
pineapple pizza has arrived oh you like
that Annie
sorry action we're gone how good the
crust is here it's a great pizza let's
try a little salad break oh hell yeah
you get the acidic salad
bounce back to your sweet and meaty
cheesy pizza listen as a Cavs fan I went
through many many years with LeBron
James was the only great player on that
team and we couldn't win championship
Pizza LeBron but you can't win the
championship with LeBron only no you got
to have those salad players so much
pressure being a pizza Adam the salad of
our team mmm it's more like the
marshmallow
I was not expecting Nancy to suggest
pineapple and ham pizza we got a pizza
to go as well because two pizzas it
wasn't enough one of the quintessential
salad and pizza herrings doesn't have
this salad component at all but rather
than dressing yes talking about ranch on
pizza
forgive us a Nancy you want you want
emotion I know we're just dipping go
we're doing this driving the car neaten
pizza with ranch I gotta make this mall
right there he took Joe's Shanghai kid
hmm I don't know any almost hurled
they're definitely pretty good I just
had a bite without ranch it's way better
got a ranch fact Hidden Valley Ranch is
responsible for introducing ranch
dressing ranch style dressings are now
the favorite salad dressing flavor in
the u.s. to state that you're the first
of anything very impressive we're
heading now downtown to a place called
the manufacturing this is a giant
complex that has bakeries a couple of
restaurants a market space one of the
restaurants in that space Tartine Bianco
is where we're going next and we're
meeting up with Chris Bianco one of the
creative visionaries behind that space
as well as chef de cuisine Camden
Hershberger so we're having egg Liotta a
classic Italian steak preparation
typically served with a small arugula
salad so are we getting a steak or
rigging a salad both before or during
Robin and with Robin comes Batman that's
right I don't want to eat bats though or
Birds
well not like birds is about a brick bat
is a mammal they have nipples
we're in the manufacturing built 1917
most recently American about was here
before and they manufacture clothes now
we manufacture well I guess the earth
manufacturers that's kind of the crux of
our work is trying not to screw up
what's already perfect my part of child
in my collaboration is really about
finding incredibly talented young chefs
like chef Camden tortilla Bianco and
working with them to being a band not a
solo artist today we're going to be
trying this tagliata what is that dish
okay yeah uh you know sorry I wasn't
saying that right ya know gee you know
many times they slide the G like slice
thick but it sounds about 30 ounce bone
in New York cut about two inches thick
the beef we get from small farms either
in Washington or Northern California we
grill that over almond wood presented
with the bone just in case you want kind
of non adapter where Stephen always
gnaws on the bone actually it's
recommended yeah okay good I'm glad I'm
justified here the salad is constructed
seconds before the steak a slice arugula
it's dressed in sherry vinegar olive oil
salt and a little lemon juice it has to
be fresh because as soon as the salt
hits those greens it's pulling the
moisture out through osmosis
why arugula it's nice and peppery what
do you need with a piece of protein what
do you crave you know for us something
bitter something cut back so that's the
job of a salad yes you have the steak
that's beefy and heavy and rich then you
have the salad it's light its crisp it's
a city as we get older I think we
realize the secret to any of it because
balance yes like when you're younger
it's volume all I want to do is make it
louder
and then finally find out what's the
tipping point of volume I think maturing
is uh is restraint
holding something back enough so people
can read that chairs even chairs salads
[Music]
that's a sick one I know what Adam come
here and drink this wine
all right let's bread I wanted the
Porsche first look how spongy this is
literally incorporated porridge into the
dough it's such a moist crawler is it my
first time having Tartine bread Cheers
this is Wow
the texture is very unique yeah it's
like gummy in a satisfying way hmm
we had to start with the bread because
tart team famous for their bread they're
baking loaves all day so you had some
bread while you wait for your salad to
come but of course it's not the salad
that's taking a long time it's the giant
steak we're having alongside of it thank
you
whoa net salad in all fairness the salad
is 50 percent of this plate right now
cheers take chairs
[Music]
Andrew wow that's a great salad this
might be the best date that we've had on
the show yeah it cooks your whole mouth
it feels like your mouth is drowning in
flavor
this time I'm gonna follow up with the
salad right away I can already feel
myself getting ready for the salad
[Music]
[Applause]
yeah that rocks it just kind of like
deletes the steak from my mouth so that
the next time that I eat it it's like
the first time again steak and salad
opposites you my friend are the steak
slow rich beefy me the arugula a little
bitter a little peppery a nice cut into
your sarcastic tone okay yeah I am proud
to say I him the salad of this duo if
you're this salad you should be proud
Kim did mention the dandelion and celery
salad
I think Adam should eat that what a wild
place that feels like Disneyland for
food they've paid some watch attention
to detail I mean we walked in there and
Andrew could not get over how much he
loved the chairs there oh my god before
we get to our worth it winners three
favorite things from today that weren't
salads oh go okay number three the bread
at Tartine oh so good number two Scott
Lloyd and the ambrosia salad you took us
way deep and dark into the salad vortex
on that one number one though the sign
I'd love to eat that said caution of
spiciness what are you okay number three
pink milk at love to eat oh yeah that
was wild
number two the butter swoosh at 13
Bianco it's stuff like that that just
really tickles me and my number one
favorite moment from this video that
wasn't a salad is I've had your seat
heater on for all the car rides so far
and you haven't noticed it's like 80
degrees today what does your butt feel
like right now no it just feels like
normal normal hot ass all that being
said Andrew which salad was the most
worth it to you my worth it winner today
love to eat papaya salad bright acidic
spicy hearing that people just eat that
as their meal with sticky rice I'm gonna
start doing that Steven who's your worth
of winter so the tagliata
was perhaps the perfect state well that
being said my worth winner goes to the
papaya salad
I cannot believe him saying that cuz I
cannot believe I'm agreeing with you
Annie
make sense Adam who's your worth a
winner
Oh with the celery sale oh wow yeah that
salad is super good you know in when
you're playing Madden I don't I've never
played it okay never mind
[Music]
[Applause]
you